I am colorectal cancer and my tuber is on the outside of my rectum.
I've been doing chemo for a year and a half and it's been the same chemo every two weeks
and every three been getting this chemo. In the beginning results were good but recently
I had scans done and the results showed that the cancer now is spreading again to my lymph node
and the original tuber has no increase to get in size lately it feels like the chemo is hurting
the tuber more than helping. Let's not right there this is another point that we've talked about
in the last few sessions that we've had and that it's good to switch up the therapy you know
I know that we we have had people that have been on a therapy for a very long time whether it be a
natural therapy or a standard unclogical therapy like a chemo or like a butyl therapy
with really good results and the oncologist doesn't want to change things and I understand that
and I it's like okay if things are going well then maybe don't change anything but sometimes
the cancer is finding other fuel sources and finding a workaround with something that you're doing
and you just need to make changes. I don't understand why your colitis wouldn't make a change here
or wouldn't be the first one to recommend we got to stop this and change something else because
usually they do but certainly if what you're doing now the cancer is found to work around around this
you need to make some changes either you just completely stop the chemotherapy all together and
we have to weeding you need to contact me because we should have a phone call and relook at your
natural therapy as well because that should be changed as well if there's a change in your cancer
like this and or you you talk to your oncologist about changing the chemotherapy now
been doing four different chemotherapy drugs there might not be anything from a chemotherapy
perspective to change too and maybe that's why your oncologist isn't like we need to change things
right away because he doesn't have any other tools in his tool bag well we have to from a natural
perspective make some changes if the cancers found a workaround found another way to grow found another
a pathway to feed itself that you need to make changes it's just as simple as that
that possible the chemo can be negatively affecting the tumor it's probably not like feeding off
the chemo so it's it's supporting the chemo the chemo is supporting the tumor that's probably not
it but the if the if the chemo isn't killing it at all then the chemo is just hurting your
old immune system and then from a secondary standpoint the chemo is allowing the cancer to grow
unabated because your immune system is is becoming neutralized by the chemo so if it was me I would
make a decision it's not the chemo immediately can my body get get immune to the chemo as it does with
a supplement already tails yep exactly so it's not that your body's getting immune to something but
you're it's it's at the cancers getting smart remember your cancer is your old cells it's
they're just trying to stay alive so we just we you have to switch things up sometime so
schedule a time that we can talk we should do another cheek swab and we should just do a complete
new workout for sure